hello and welcome to this release I knew
we're in this video I'm going to discuss
some new information about two different
companies that are currently developing
cell therapies for treatment for covered
19 and so these two companies are pleura
stem therapeutics and ethicists so I
recently watched the webinar just the
other day that was produced by the
Alliance for regenerative medicine and
they had speakers from both glory stem
and a thesis talked about their current
work and so the video is available on
YouTube but it's part an hour long so in
this video I just planned to summarize
the key points and take-home messages
from the talk so as I mentioned before
these companies are developing cell
therapy treatments and so what
effectively this means our therapies in
which viable cells are injected grafted
or implanted into a patient's so
ethicist and Glory stem therapeutics are
not the only two companies developing
cell therapy treatments but they were
two in the webinar and so they're the
ones I'm going to talk about and so both
of these companies and I'll trying to
use their products to try and reduce and
alleviate the symptoms that are
associated with patients with cable 19
so in particular this includes acute
respiratory distress syndrome otherwise
known as odds but also potentially the
other complications such as the acute
kidney injury and gastro intestinal
injury seen in some patients and so I
think around a month ago now I made a
video about this in terms of a thesis
and so I'll just reiterates a couple of
points that I said then about the
company so a thesis is a biotechnology
company that is focusing on regenerative
medicine which is the process of
repairing engineering or regenerating
human or animals tissues or organs to be
able to get back the initial function of
that tissue so before this outbreak even
a cards ethicists were using their own
product which they called multi stem -
investigates
its properties and being able to prevent
the symptoms of arts
and so this multi stem product that I'm
talking about is the own product that
they've developed which are effectively
it's a stem cell product and so stem
cells are cells that have the capability
to regenerate and generate more cells
also the ability to divide and
differentiate and so they initially took
these cells from healthy adults bone
marrow and because they have this
capability to devise they can then
expand them outside of the human body
and produce more of them and say there's
no genetic manipulations but these cells
they've expanded they can then freeze
for them thorine for when they're needed
in therapies and then the really cool
thing about these multi stands is that
these multi stem cells is that they
don't need blood or tissue type matching
which is actually a really severe
limitation of transplants so the
developments of this products could
therefore be widely available to
multiple patients or needs and the way
that they delivered these cells is
intravenously so Eric Jenkins was
speaking on behalf of a thesis during
this webinar and he went into a bit more
detail about that McKay via trial which
stands for multi stem administration for
K vat19 induced odds and so this is a
Phase III trial that they have FDA
approval for whereby they want to get
400 subjects and do a double-blind
randomly SIBO trial and after 28 days of
given these multi stands they want to do
primary clinical assessments and then
obviously they would do a 12-month
follow-up to assess the quality of life
and health of the patients so the one
thing I didn't really talk about in the
previous video I did about a thesis was
how these multi stem cells are actually
going to be able to achieve this and to
alleviate the symptoms and increase
recovery of the patients and so
described in this webinar Eric talks
about the multiple ways that multi stem
cells effectively modulate the immune
system and so don't worry if you didn't
understand
there is different cells I've talked
about that but the key point is is from
there in theory studies and other data
they generally see by having these mozi
stem cells they see a reduction in
pro-inflammatory factors such as
interleukin 6 and 8 and interleukin-1
beta and increase of interleukin 10
tgf-beta and interleukin 4 and so what
they propose the effect of this is is to
tip the balance of the immune system
from a hypo inflammatory States to
patroller a genic one so the really key
point to understand is that these multi
stem cells actually secrete factors into
the surrounding tissue and into the
blood system and these different factors
have hopefully the potential to regulate
the immune system to be able to protect
damaged and injured cells to be able to
promote tissue repair and healing and
then after this has happens over time
these cells are going to be cleared from
the body so kind of what makes these
cell therapy is very different to the
taking of drugs is that they're
secreting a whole bunch of factors that
could have a die first and even more
effective response than just taking one
compound so what about clarice them so
clarice them is a leading regenerative
medicine company that are developing
novel placenta base cell therapy
products so unlike ethicist that took
them from bay marrow the Cloe stem
company is using placental expanded
cells hence the name of their products
which they call PL X and say as guess by
the name they are derived from the
placenta and similarly to the multi stem
cells they are mesenchymal like stromal
cells but they had the same stem cell
capability
and so these cells are taken from the
placenta which is known to protect and
sustain the developing fetus and it also
protects the fetus from attack from the
mother's immune response and also from
an infection and so the idea is kind of
like the same effect it's got to happen
right they want to be able to prevent it
and I mean response which is the idea
behind the dampening the response to
keep it 19 which is thought to cause
odds I'm sorry because these cells have
this stem cell-like properties they can
be taken from donated placenta and then
cultured in what they have their own
technology to replicate emperatriz tons
of these plx cells so they can
manufacture them in large numbers and
then they can take the sell products and
freeze them and throw them when they're
needed and also similarly to atlases
there are lots of these that that shows
that these cells have immunomodulatory
properties such that they can induce the
regulatory T cells and the MT
macrophages and the bottom line to this
is that hopefully it can prevent or
reverse the dangerous over activation of
the immune system that is seen in
particular with severe cases of cave of
19 but the key difference between this
product and atlases is instead of it
being in Japan you ously injected these
cells are provided intramuscularly so if
you go into the websites or I've heard
these companies you'll find probably a
lot more information and nicer diagrams
and my own scribbly writing but I took
this image from the florist and websites
and so you can see that they have this
intramuscular injection of these percent
cells and again juice these secreted
factors that are listed here the idea is
that has a systemic impacts on the body
which hopefully could leave e8 the
symptoms that occur freak in cave of 19
patients so similarly to other says they
also now have FDA approval to do a phase
2 trial in cave or 19 patients but they
have already used
the pl excels in ass make small cohorts
of patients and so this was a total of
18 patients and so far they have data
from eight of them after a 28-day
follow-up and so eighty-seven point five
percent was the survival rate with 75%
of the patients no longer needing any
mechanical ventilation and so in this
neutral they're now going to evaluate
the efficacy and safety of one or two
intramuscular injections in three
different dosages of these plx cells for
the treatment of odds resulting from
cavern 18 but get kids to pay for these
companies obviously is a safety and
tolerability and the kind of goals is to
be able to increase the number of days
free from the intensive care units and
the days free from these offense lasers
and hopefully from a one-year follow-up
to see an improved quality of life and
so kind of the main question or the
thing that most people are interested in
is what and when are we going to be able
to start seeing some of these therapies
actually being used for a wide variety
of patients and the problem is very much
depends on how the trials go and say
both of these companies are in the
recruitment stage and obviously it
therefore depends on the success of
these trials and also depends on how
these companies if the are effective
will be able to scale up their products
so I said it could be applied to
multiple patients
but as I said I mean it's very
interesting for these to understand
these therapies and obviously pay for
them were initially designed to treat
other diseases and so it's kind of
exciting that this push to further
develop and refine these treatments are
being done but hopefully yet we'll see
some success and hopefully it will help
a lot of patients out who are struggling
and suffering with cave at 19 so
hopefully you've learnt something and as
always thanks listening